we had some other controversy on the
show last time we're on two weeks ago
and I promised I would address it two
weeks ago I did a new rule on our
internet overtime segment about someone
named Zayn Malik who I'd never heard of
until that day but who apparently had
just left the boy band One Direction
well the PC police as usual read way
more into the joke than was actually
there so tonight we're unveiling a new
segment called explaining jokes to
idiots
so I'm going to reshow the joking
question and we'll stop the tape
periodically to explain what's going on
roll up new rules aim not right there
let me say about this new rule is merely
a framing device for the purposes of
comedy new rules are not legally binding
are not actual regulations and do not
carry the force of law
back to the tape knurl Zayn Malik can
just go ahead and quit one direction for
all I care
I mean whatever you see the audience is
laughing here because I'm taking on the
attitude and dialect of a 12 year old
girl when clearly I'm not a 12 year old
girl I'm a 28 year old man roll tape but
I think after everything we've been
through I at least deserve the common
respect of being told face to face okay
for you comedy students out there this
is called milking the premise you see
now that I have the audience believing I
care deeply about what happens to the
band One Direction me it's one to get
your old man I take it even further and
imply that Zayn and I have a personal
relationship oh gosh what am I going to
do next let's see just tell me two
things Jane which one in the band were
you
okay here we get to what we in the
comedy business called the old
switcheroo where my previous sentiments
are revealed to be sarcastic and we
unveil that in reality I have no idea
who this guy is nor do I give a and
I don't I was a teenager in the 70s my
idea of a boy band is crosby Stills and
Nash in fact I was calling Zane Zion in
rehearsal because we had it spelled
wrong but our staff caught it before
showtime
it's called fact-checking rolling stone
look into it alright here comes the
final punchline or what we call the
topper which one in the band were you
and where were you during the Boston
Marathon Oh
now notice how the crowd was shocked at
first but in just a few seconds they
were cracking up and applauding that's
because they're not idiots and they
understand or get what the joke is that
they look alike
that's it their facial features are
quite similar which is humorous because
one is a murderer
and the other isn't a boyband where they
only murdered the music now it turns out
Zayn Malik is a Muslim but neither I nor
anyone on our staff knew that how could
we the whole joke is I don't know who
the he is I don't know his religion
or his birthday or his favorite food
because I don't spend every waking hour
obsessing over teenage boys like a
Catholic I mean a twelve-year-old like
its well dear old girl and by the way if
you are a twelve-year-old girl you have
every right to be upset because you're
12 but for all the respectable media
outlets who covered this story when you
could have spent time and space on real
news that needs reporting you are not
only traitors to journalism you are in
the truest sense of the word
twelve-year-old girls
you